bonsoir françois bayrou comme choix
merci d'être venu sur notre plateau vous
êtes le président du modem le maire de
pau vous avez déjeuné avec le président
de la république dès le lendemain des
élections voulues avait parlé comme aux
chefs de partis hier à l'élysée voulu
parler régulièrement bon nous il nous a
parlé ce soir on a essayé de comprendre
ce qu'il a dit c'est à dire de quelle
façon il avait pris acte de cette
nouvelle donne politique qui était cette
minorité pour la majorité sortante voilà
alors elle est majoritaire mais très
relative il a dit qu'il fallait
gouverner et légiférer différemment
bâtir des compromis écoutée respectée
mais pas rester dans l'immobilisme est
ce que ce n'est pas un peu de flou tout
ça on sait pas encore totalement précisé
on va dire non quand c'est flou et donc
il faut qu est ce qu il faut retenir de
cette intervention c'est le président de
la république qui prend acte des
résultats
c'est la première chose est ce qu'il a
fait à ses d'autocritique sur sa
personne sa manière de il ya des jouets
président et il ya des gens qui adorent
les autocritiques mais comme vous savez
je n'en suis pas je pense que très
souvent c'est de l'hypocrisie on se on
se bat la coupe
en se couvrant la tête de cendres mais
ça n'aurait pas été utile
non je pense que c'est pas le sujet
les français ont adressé
à la nation tout entière et au président
de la république en particulier et à
tous les responsables politiques
un message qui pour moi est extrêmement
clair vous devez changer votre manière
de gouverner
est ce que le président de la république
a dit dans une phrase
j'imagine précisé nous devons légiférer
et gouverné autrement alors ça n'est pas
seulement des mots pour moi
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse continuer
comme ça je j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
vous le dire à ce micro je pense qu'on
se trompe ray on se tromperait à vouloir
édulcorer le message c'est ce qui fait
la non non
il a dit voir ce que vous pensez il
après non mais je veux dire voilà vous
dit hey mais on gagnerait à l'émail
ville coréenne meena donc est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il ait vu le corps le
message je dis toujours très précisément
ce que je pense parce que c'est le seul
moyen d'avoir un peu d'authenticité je
dis qu'il faut changer
le rapport entre les gouvernants et le
peuple des citoyens je pense qu'il faut
changer la manière dont on se comporte
quand on est au pouvoir
je pense qu'au lieu de décider et de
faire appliquer doux de décider de telle
ou telle réforme est de penser que ceux
qui doivent la voter vont la voter d'un
bloc aveuglément
il faut au contraire
bâtir ses réformes les construire avec
eux sans leur demander de renier leur
identité
c'est ce que j'avais appelé en sortant
de l'elysée hier
s'approcher au plus près possible de
l'union nationale pourquoi j'ai dit au
plus près possible parce que je sais
bien que c'est impossible
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez dit
abadie nationale possible élan même s'il
a dit le président il a dit qu'est ce
que alors peut-être on peut expliquer
les maux union nationale qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que toutes les
forces politiques dans un contexte de
guerre par exemple disent on va se
mettre tout ensemble pour essayer de
faire quelque chose de bien l'union
nationale
et donc ça voudrait dire avec les feux
la france insoumise avec le rassembleur
nationale et ça vous dit c'est exprès
pas seulement avec elle mais par exemple
l air a pas du tout l'intention d'entrer
j'ai l'impression d'entrer dans son
contrat de gouvernement parce qu'ils
sont fait lire dans l'opposition
pourquoi peut-on imaginer leur demander
d'entrer dans la majorité l'idée qu'
il suffit de recréer la majorité qui n'a
pas été donnée par les électeurs est une
idée que moi je ne crois pas possible
donc vous êtes indiqué magna macron se
trompent aujourd'hui non là je
n'essayez pas de
mettre le feu entre nous
il se trouve que ce sont des sujets dont
je parle très souvent mais c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas entendu le message non je
pense qu'il a parfaitement entendu le
message et que ce qu'il en a dit sur
deux ou trois sujets les fractures du
pays le fait qu'il va falloir désormais
chercher des compromis et le fait qu' on
doit légiférer et gouverné autrement ce
sont des mots qui ont été
choisis j'imagine
ça dit quelque chose d'essentiel mais je
pense qu on se tromperait en édulcorant
ce qui est en train de se passer en
faisant comme si se passait pas grand
chose au fond comme si c'était à peu
près normale je crois que c'est un d une
des dernières chances offertes pour
qu'on ressaisissent la situation et
qu'on essaie de
manifester par l'attitude par le style
par la présence par la manière d'être
que les français ont été entendus alors
attendez parce que quand moi je vous
entends j'entends une critique du
maquereau nisme j'entends une critique
du style les manuels macron du
fonctionnement des manuels macron du
fonctionnement de ses ministres et on va
et venir de sa première ministre on va y
venir mais ce que vous dites là c'est
les parisiens les techno les déraciner
les gens d'en haut enfin tout ce qu'on
entend à droite à gauche finalement vous
souscrivez cette thèse et cela il faut
plus les il faut plus qui sommes nous
avons eu chaud pas combien d'interviews
dans notre vie commune mais un assez
grand nombre
je crois pas qu'il y en ait une seule où
je ne vous ai pas dit qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui n'allait plus dans
comme shakespeare aurait dit au royaume
de danemark dans notre manière
d'envisager la vie publique là quelque
chose qui ne va plus qu est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui ne va plus et on
n'arrive pas à expliquer aux citoyens ce
qu'on veut faire
ils ne peuvent pas y participer ils ne
se sentent pas reconnus au sens au sens
personnel du terme mais
n'allons pas trop vite parce que vous
les médias vous êtes pris là dedans
aussi d'ailleurs exactement la même
chose mois soit on essaie d'expliquer
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un langage par
exemple technocratique est assez
difficile à voilà lorsque je crois mais
eux
c'est pardon c'est une notation qui va
vous paraître
trop simple et peut-être un peu étrange
je pense qu'il ya un face à face entre
ceux qui sont d'un côté de l'écran
ceux qui sont de l'autre côté et que le
langage des uns la parole des uns n'est
plus comprise par les autres tant qu'on
ne se rendra pas compte que ce qui est
en cause ce qui gravement en cause dans
le résultat de ces élections mais dans
l'abstention dans ce qui est gravement
en cause c'est la manière dont nous
exerçons le pouvoir est-ce que vous ne
sais pas est ce que c'est pas ce qui est
gravement en cause c'est que nous mêmes
nous ne sommes pas au pouvoir
suffisamment franchir mois françois
bayrou je suis un guerrier ministre ceci
est ridicule d'accord parce que il se
trouve que je me suis présenté trois
fois à l'élection présidentielle excusez
moi je suis pas à demander des des
places ou des avantages les avantages ou
les places je les gagne mais je ne les
quémande pas donc de ce point de vue là
soyons soyons certains vous vous rendez
vous ne vous rendez pas que vous êtes
entre regardons précisément cette
séquence de trois jours et votre phrase
je le dis avec eux oui pas de problème
je vous pose des questions vous me
répondez vous avez le droit d'être
absolument solaire éventuellement qu'un
nouvel homme fort mais question il n'y a
aucun problème on a une élection
législative
qui est non pas la première comme tout à
l'heure c'était l'ancien troisièmement
c'est au moins la deuxième louis ménard
58 aussi voilà il n'y avait pas la
majorité pour général de la l'époque le
président de république n'était pas élu
au suffrage universel
c'est quand même peut-être la troisième
est là c'est la deuxième fois que le
président de la république n'a pas la
majorité et sur une décision qui est une
décision j'allais dire mûrement
réfléchie du pays parce que là on a eu
une campagne on a dit voilà avec des
surprises formidable ou impressionnante
le surgissement du front national en est
une le le relatif insuccès de la france
insoumise en est une tout ça il ya eu
plein de surprises mais il ya une chose
qu'on sait c'est que les électeurs ont
voté ceux qui ont voté ils ont voté en
connaissance de cause il ya trois jours
c'est une élection qui est pour moi une
sorte de tremblements de terre on va
dire ça les choses comme ça mais et vous
direz vous le mercredi soir vous dites
mais au fond est-ce que c'est pas parce
que la place du parti politique dont
vous êtes le président le responsable
n'est pas suffisante on a cinquante
députés et un peu plus bon franchement
il ya beaucoup de gens qui voudraient
être là ça n'est pas ce que je dis
elle criait écoutez moi sur ce point
nous avons une crise démocratique majeur
on peut faire semblant une fois de plus
orange entend très bien alors donnez moi
vos solutions parce que moi je peux voir
aussi dans cette assemblée nationale un
de vos désirs qui est la proportionnelle
même si ça ne l'est pas complètement
c'est à dire une représentation à peu
près réel pam part exacte ovo centimes
au centimètre près de la société
française et on peut s'en féliciter
aussi oui donc voilà ce que oui mais
jean que précisé danger sur vous les
verts de plus maintenant concrètement je
suis en train de faire c'est à dire on a
enfin les français entendent enfin
obtenu le pluralisme parlementaires
qu'ils attendaient alors le chemin a été
un peu compliqué un peu bizarre ils sont
arrivés à ce résultat par un passionné
par un scrutin majoritaire
étrange parce que s'ils avaient eu la
proportionnelle chacune des forces de
gauche se serait présenté sous ses
couleurs et donc le dialogue aurait été
plus simple est peut-être on aurait eu
des manifestations de cet ordre à droite
aussi c'aurait été le plus plus clair
mais mettons ça de côté je pense qu'il
faut que l'on sorte de l'idée que les
décisions sont prises
dans un lieu unique et ensuite adopté
quasi automatiquement ce ça qu'on dit
quand on dit on va faire une majorité
celle là où une plus large moi je pense
que la construction des décisions doit
se faire en tenant compte des
différentes sensibilités en tenant
compte
[Musique]
de la présidentielle
les gouvernements sont sont là pour ça
je pense vous avez je crois que j'ai dit
même à votre micro mon
mon idéal d'institutions c'est un
président fort on l'a il était au
suffrage universel un gouvernement fort
et un parlement fort le parlement fort
en la maintenant enfin il est disons à
parlement indocile et sait très bien que
les parements soit un docile et un
gouvernement fort et pour l'instant le
lam la personne veut dire autonome par
rapport au président au kansas autonome
politiquement autonome d'une île où ne
peut pas être indépendant du président
puisqu'il est nommé par lui mais le
président le nomme pour qu'ils soient en
situation de responsabilité pour qu'il
propose lui de vous souvenez que du
texte de la constitution l'article 20
qui dit le le gouvernement détermine et
conduit la politique de la nation et moi
je trouve très bien ces discussions
qu'on a très souvent avec le président
de la république en dehors de tout de
tout contexte je trouve très bien qu'on
ait deux sources de légitimité le
président et le gouvernement
et cette fois ci je pense nécessaire
qu'on change le
logiciel sur ces sujets allez donc c'est
pas c'est pas des petites choses
médiocre dans lesquelles nous sommes
c'est pas des questions de marchandage
non l homme dans une conception
différente des institutions dans
laquelle moi je crois pas du tout à
l'idée qu'on va faire un pacte de
gouvernement avec les formations
politiques qui ont été élus dans
l'opposition je pense qu'elle ne
voudrait pas et que ça serait au fond
pas totalement les respectant les
électeurs par exemple des républicains
lorsqu'ils entendent un président macron
pour lequel ils ont voté souvent au
premier tour de la présidentielle en
bonne partie
leur dire qu'ils veulent qui veut un
programme dans lesquelles il ya des
progrès sur la souveraineté du progrès
écologique de la sécurité de la justice
qui soit crédible et financé sans
baisses d'impôts et s'endettent
augmentation de la dette bah il peut ça
peut sonner
joliment à leurs oreilles et c'est pas
une question d'alliance ou de paille ans
c'est exactement ce que je vous dis je
pense que les lois votées doivent être
travaillés avec les oppositions au temps
où pas autant avec les oppositions
comme on le fait avec les majorités je
pense et moi un exemple bah écoutez ce
je vais prendre un exemple très simple
parce qu'il s'est réalisé quand le
ministre de l'économie qui s'appelait
emmanuel macron à l'époque a voulu faire
une loi nouvelle sur la modernisation de
l'économie il a passé deux mois à
travailler avec des oppositions oui mais
il a eu 1 49 3 parce qu'ils n'ont que
quelques voix non pas du tout bah c'est
pas du tout si vous si vous lisez le
texte du premier ministre de l'époque il
a dit que c'était pas vrai il manquait
des voix dans la majorité il va pas dans
l'opposition à la majorité les voies d
opposition elle était là oui mais
c'était le fender
à l'intérieur de la majorité une forme
de poésie seconde et donc c'est
complètement
illégitime de comparer l'air comment
vous faites ce gouvernement parce que
bon tout le monde vous a entendu ce
matin chez nos confrères de france inter
dire une phrase qui a jailli au franc ce
qui a blessé la première ministre
sommant pas
je pense que la première ministre est
quelqu'un de très bien elle le sait
parce que on se parle il y avait parlé
aujourd'hui non mais je l'aurais
l'occasion demain ou après-demain jeudi
que le jeudi que vous avez d'une galette
et technicienne on aiglons il fallait un
cadre politique et dans son entourage on
a dit non mais nous on a fait
l'assurance chômage la réforme la sncf
c'est des grosses réformes difficiles on
a négocié avec les syndicats et tous
c'est pas de la politique ça ce serait
pas un peu misogyne ça c'est ça qui est
dit aujourd'hui vous me sentais misogyne
d'un coutelas j'en sais rien je prends
devant vous en savez rien tôt
que 7,7 cette attaque mais pas la taxe
en question et je leur apporte ce qui a
été dit aujourd'hui moi je dis que
l'idée qu' on ne change rien dans la
manière de gouverner est contradictoire
avec le message que les français ont
envoyé donc il faut changer de premier
ministre non je dis pas ça je dis qu'il
faut changer la manière de gouverner que
ça n'est pas seulement une adaptation
qu'on est en train de faire je dis
peut-être je suis minoritaire j'accepte
de la tour j'ai souvent été je dis
simplement qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne
va plus dans la manière dont les
français perçoivent ceux qui les
gouvernent parce que ils ne sentent pas
suffisamment de se sentent pas
suffisamment reconnus ils sentent pas
suffisamment
d'empathie comme on dit c'est à dire le
c'est à dire le partage des sentiments
qu'il fallait leur paraît autrement tout
à l'heure le président aurait dû leur
dire je vous ai compris
j'ai entendu que vous vouliez le smic à
1500 euros j'ai entendu vous vouliez pas
la retraite à 65 ans je n'en crois rien
de tout ça quoi rien de tout ça je pense
que les français sont très loin d'être
complètement aveugle en face des
problèmes du pays je ne crois pas qu'il
croit aux solutions miracles je ne crois
pas qu'ils pensent que les gouvernants
ont des baguettes magiques je crois pas
qu'ils pensent qu'il suffit d'ajouter
des zéros au chèque pour que tout se
passe très bien je crois rien de tout ça
je pense simplement qu'il faut prendre
au sérieux les messages qui sont
envoyées et prendre au sérieux les
messages qu'ils ont envoyé selon moi
c'est essayer de composer différemment
les équipes gouvernementales
d'essayer de mieux représenter les
sensibilités différentes par exemple
avoir des personnalités venues oui
d'autres univers que la politique pure
pas exactement mais pas céder des
académiciens des intellectuels des
mets pas ou des autres unités récoltées
dans l'univers politique que la majorité
pur
d'autres de
sortir de l' entre soi qui est un entre
soi de
deux manières je dis ça c'est des gens
que j'aime bien on a envie depuis
longtemps ensemble je partage leur sont
ils sont doués souvent intelligent
souvent la france ne comprend plus ses
gouvernants vous entendez ça pardon de
le dire avec un pneu de véhémence ou
trop de véhémence la la les députés
viennent d'être élus et et ce et les
ministres ont été battus vont quitter
secondes et bien ruth elkrief alors il
n'y a pas de problème
je compris jury donne acte je voudrais
qu'on peut vous tendait un cabanon des
plus grandes jambes à lyon vous êtes pas
dit non mais non monsieur la vérité mais
on peut on peut bien accepté c'est un an
je voudrais comprendre concrètement ce
que vous entendez je veux dire justement
parce que pour que les français le
comprennent façon simple pas de faim
voilà j'ai envie de retourner le contenu
le compliment c'est à dire dit les
choses clairement baby pas clair moi non
j'attends quelque chose d'encore plus
clair bas la première ministre elle
n'est pas assez politique vous l'avez
matin non que je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai
dit qu'il fallait un gouvernement moins
technique est plus politique plus
politique au sens de jeu prend entre mes
mains
les attentes le lait le profond de ce
que les citoyens
voudrez et attendent on peut continuer
comme ça on ira de d'accidents en
accident jeu comme cette émission est
enregistrée vous aurez définitivement ça
dans vos archives on ira d'accidents en
accident le monde politique s'il
fonctionne toujours pareil
il ya des élections il ya un accident
électoral le soir de l'accident et dit
oui quand même on vient de prendre une
beigne sérieuse le lendemain ils en
parlent encore deux jours après c'est
fini et on recommence comme avant on a
tort de recommencer a rapporté vendredi
la donné rendez-vous à la voilà ce que
je dis en tant que citoyen siens et en
tant que responsable politique en tout
cas en charge le langage a en charge le
langage on parle plus clairement et plus
franchement en france mais comme il
parle de tous les jours et je veux
varier mes parents mes partenaires du
mas et pas vulgaire au contraire voilà
dire de façon claire et elles sont
claires et non vulgaire non mais bien
sûr mais c'est ce que n'ont affecté et
c'est ce que nous essayons de ferrer ont
propre l'accord c'est ce que nous
essayons de faire dans les médias et moi
je trouve que je vois la ccco si simple
comme si nous pas nous parlions à des
proches et pour les choses soient
claires et avec respect évidemment bon
mais après ok très bien et ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on fait ensuite le
gouvernement devient
devient lui-même
le rédacteur des propositions et des
projets de loi qu'il discute avec les
différentes sensibilités préalablement
donkey s'autonomise par rapport au
président oui donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
en fait il y à l'elysée puis de l'autre
côté de la scène hay à matignon ayant
gouvernement est en fait il ya à pouvoir
partager ce n'est pas partagé le
le général de gaulle a dit une fois pour
toutes ce qu'il en était il dit nous
allons enlever
l'exécutif
la décision politique aux manoeuvres
parlementaires
le président de la république composera
le gouvernement en tenant compte des
nuances de l'assemblée nationale il
tient compte des nuances de l'assemblée
nationale
et on a ainsi une démarche politique est
en effet partagé entre le président de
la république et le gouvernement le
gouvernement n'étant pas seulement
l'exécutant du président de la
république mais étant le comment
dirais-je une des sources de l'action
politique donc ça veut dire que dans un
des deux un gouvernement et donnerait
qui est des représentants de plusieurs
partis ligne ou en lan politique à
personnalité qui peuvent porter une
partie des nuances politiques du pays
tout en n'étant pas le gouvernement
d'union nationale qui reda moussa sow
existant n'est pas n'est pas d'actualité
donc ça c'est votre message ce soir je
reviens quand même sur un label alors je
vais je vais essayer de trouver une
phrase un peu plus plus juste des gens
qui disent
coalition gouvernement de coalition ces
deux philippins vous m'avez dit la
semaine dernière où il ya quinze jours
quand vous étiez sur ce plateau que vous
étiez dans une bonne relation de
partenariat là on a une très bonne
relation de partenariat et on peut avoir
des nuances on sand en sont exclus moi
je crois qu'il faut non pas un
gouvernement de coalition non pas un
gouvernement d'union nationale c'est
impossible je crois qu'il faut un
gouvernement de bonne volonté
un gouvernement de bonne volonté c'est
quelqu'un c'est un gouvernement qui est
parfaitement conscient des orientations
du président de la république avec qui
il est en proximité mais qui se donne la
liberté là la puissance la légitimité de
travail et les réformes et les projets
avec les nuances y compris de ceux qui
sont pas de la majorité
mais ça va jusqu'aux arènes et jusqu'à
lé majorité on travaillait depuis très
longtemps en france depuis des décennies
comme si elle était dans un bloc
obéissant à une seule source de
légitimité
ceci a changé depuis le week-end dernier
pour moi alors il ya des tas de gens non
mais dimanche on pensait que ça avait
changé lundi le penser encore
aujourd'hui le pense plus c'est comme ça
le paris match quasiment ma compagne non
non non parce que
lui je sais que qui pensent à ça
je ne parle pas tout à fait en l'air je
sais je sais que l'immense majorité de
la culture politique au fond se
satisfait très bien que rien ne change
et mais je pense qu'il faut que de
l'intérieur y compris de l'intérieur de
la majorité y compris d'une force
politique comme la nôtre qui sommes un
peu différente du mouvement principal de
la majorité viennent et se fassent
entendre cette exigence de nouvelles
approches nouvelles méthodes et nouvelle
culture que le président a esquissé dans
son discours un gouvernement de bonne
volonté ce que vous dites c'est votre
définition à côté de ceux qui veulent
une coalition et notamment avec les
républicains soyons clair parce que mais
justement bon il serait impossible je
l'examinerai peut-être sympathiquement
mais ce n'est pas possible aujourd'hui
vous comprenez maintenant bien vous
voyez bien vous ne pouvez pas demander à
cadet jean élu dans l'opposition tient
de venir le lendemain matin se ranger
dans la majorité ou alors est ce que
c'est moi qui ai type qui est pas les
yeux en face des trous la coalition avec
les républicains ça semble exclue pour
vous donc vous dites de la même façon un
gouvernement qui finalement part avec sa
feuille de route mais qui au cas par cas
va chercher vague l'année comme en 1988
n'ont pas se les voir va être lui même
la source d'un certain nombre de
propositions nouvelles
c'est de ça dont on a besoin article 20
le gouvernement détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation j'avais proposé
ya très longtemps qu'on écrive le
président déterminé le gouvernement
conduit la politique de la nation c'est
parce qu'elle a été choisie
le
au fond on a besoin des trois pôles
forts le président faure le parlement
fort et le gouvernement fort et ce qui
manque aujourd'hui c'est un gouvernement
fort c'est que le gouvernement soit
considérée par tout le monde comme fort
par les forces parlementaires avec ils
dialoguent à ce que vous demandez un
changement de premier ministre parce que
c'est ce que vous nous direz que la
première ministre est assez forte
gouvernement est assez marrant dans mes
déclarations j'ai dit comme comme
quelqu'un qui estime la vème république
c'est au président de la république d'en
décider là il va se lancer dans son
épisode
européens d'abord ensuite internationale
dans l'es7
mais pendant ce temps il va continuer à
réfléchir
je suis persuadé que ce temps là doit
permettre au président de la république
de réfléchir à ce nouvel équilibre il a
dit nouvelle méthode des nouvelles
démarches quelque chose comme ça à ce
nouvel équilibre dont on a besoin parce
que sans ça on va se retrouver une fois
de plus avec un pays qui a le sentiment
qu'il a dit quelque chose et il l'a dit
assez fort mais que au fond non business
as usual non mais c'est pas possible
puisque ya pas de majorité absolue donc
en fait c'est impossible donc de toute
façon il va y avoir des modifications
des dix pêcheurs en eaux profondes en je
plaide pour des changements profonds
voilà alors je suis beau sans doute don
quichotte sans doute minoritaire je veux
bien tout ce qu'on veut j'accepte tout
ça mais je dis alors avec le sentiment
de gravité d'un citoyen de base qui n'en
peut plus de voir cette succession
d'accidents je dis qu'il faut qu'on
prenne à bras le corps les nécessités de
leurs la gravité des problèmes
et qu'en effet on montre de manière
claire que les choses doivent changer
voilà ce que je crois et que je plaide
le ont fait des gouvernements technicien
il faut faire des gouvernements
politique alors c'est plus la mode
depuis longtemps
on croit que qu'avec des élus avec des
élus locaux avec des biens a déjà fait
des expériences de vie différentes y en
a plus bas c'est la plus beaucoup trop
d'énarques quoi en fait non pas
seulement c'est bien qu'ils en aient
mais il faut pas une seule culture au
pouvoir
on a le sentiment que qui a une
monoculture du pouvoir que tout le monde
est passé par le même moule que le
langage la langue est devenue exactement
la même qu'est ce que vous répondez à
jean luc mélenchon qui a dit ce soir le
choix n'est pas l'art à tatouille il
faut pas biaiser avec la réalité et la
première ministre doit se présenter
présenté son programme d'action et
solliciter la confiance de l'assemblée
nationale c'est la 4ème république
qu'on a le droit d'être pour la
quatrième ou pour la 6ème ce qui est à
peu près la même chose le san et par
l'élection législative qui fait le
gouvernement c'est le président de la
république qui fait le gouvernement mais
il le fait en tenant compte de ce que le
pays a exprimé pour les législatives
voilà pourquoi je plaide pour que oui on
prenne les choses à bras le corps avec
gravité
c'est plus confortable de ne rien
changer vous savez c'est ce qui s'est
passé ce soir c'est ce qui va se passer
dans ce il ya dans la déclaration du
président de la république
des éléments qui sont des éléments de
change mouvement fort est ce qu'ils vont
porter de moi je le souhaite je le dis
sans je le lui ai dit sans sens biaisé
parce que après tout c'est notre
responsabilité vous êtes vous êtes
alliés et vous restez allier allier en
confiance à ces amicaux je crois et
francs dans le langage donc vous
demander à voir et vous attendez de voir
quoi quand même non je pense que les que
les jours qui s'ouvre ou que les
discours de ce soir ne pas être
considérée comme la clôture d'un cycle
mais comme l'ouverture d'un cycle mais
il peut y avoir une situation à laquelle
vous vous rendriez cette alliance non
c'est parce que ce que je dis je j'ai
pas l'habitude de changer d'avis tous
les quatre matins mais je pense que même
si c'est inconfortable
il doit y avoir y compris dans la
majorité des gens qui soutiennent
la nécessité de prendre au sérieux ce
que les français ont dit au sérieux un
gouvernement de bonne volonté un
gouvernement fort et qui finalement
duquel émane d'un certain nombre de
propositions après avoir entendu ce qui
se passe à l'assemblée nationale j'ai
bien réussi la vème république merci
beaucoup merci françois bayrou